For this problem, we're going to be doing something
similar to what we've done in a previous homework where you were given
a magic function to use for a reduction.
You're provided with a function solvevc
which solves vertex cover for a given graph represented
as an adjacency matrix, as we've seen previously.
Now, it returns a minimum cover of the graph as a list of 0s and 1s
where 1 means the corresponding vertex is in the cover,
and 0 means that it is not.
Now, what you should do here is use solvevc
to write a function multisolve which takes as its inputs
an adjacency matrix and a string.
The adjacency matrix is simply a graph,
and the string is either vertex cover, independent set, or clique,
and it returns a list of 0s and 1s, which are assignments of the vertices
where 1 means the corresponding vertex is in the solution
to the corresponding problem, and 0 means that it is not.
Now, you can feel free to use any additional functions you might feel are necessary.
But to be graded correctly, you have to use solvevc in the solution to your problem.